[Müzik]
Dünyamız sonsuz karanlığın içerisinde o
güzel mavi küre bir mücevher gibi
yakınımızda neredeyse hiçbir yaşam yok
En azından öyle zannediyoruz varsa
milyonlarca yıl ışık yılı ötede ve biz
bu gez de yaşıyoruz ta şu Tepede bir
yerlerde Arap yarımadasının üstünde
ama unutuyoruz orada yaşadığımızı
kalkıyoruz sabah Gözlerimiz
Eee çapaklı gidiyoruz Hemen açıyoruz
banyonun ışığını bir yüzümüzü yıkıyoruz
sonra dişlerimizi fırçalıyoruz sonra
yola koyuluyoruz ne yapacağız işe
gideceğiz işte araba sürüyoruz toplu
taşımayla gidiyoruz servislerle
gidiyoruz bazen saatlerce sürüyor Ve
sonunda iş yerimize
ulaşıyoruz harala gala harala gala
harala gala harala gala Çalışıyoruz
bütün gün boyunca çalışıyoruz en sonunda
Aynı yoldan tekrar eve gidiyoruz artık
bitmişiz tükenmiş oturuyoruz koltuğa
açıyoruz
televizyonu ve
kayboluyoruz uyu yakalıyoruz Ah
kalkıyoruz gidiyoruz yatağı buluyoruz
Ertesi sabah o ışığı yakıp Diş fırçasını
elimize al
suyu açtığımızda yine aynı döngüye
tekrar tekrar giriyoruz ama bizden
gizlenen bir gerçek var O gerçek
de bizim
esasında ne kadar az suya sahip
olduğumuz işte bildiğimiz bütün su bu di
Soluduğumuz hava var ya suyumuz çok daha
fazla değil Halbuki zannediyoruz ki
atmosfer böyle 7 kat sonsuza kadar giden
bir şey hiç Sonu Yokmuş gibi ama olan
bütün hava işte bu ve biz bu havayı
oturup kömürlü termik santrallerden
doğalgaz Çevrim santrallerinden gelen
fosil
yakıtlarla bir sürü karbondioksiti o
küçücük hava kabarcığının içerisine pomp
alıyoruz o elektriği yakabilirim diye ve
kimyasını
değiştiriyoruz bir yandan da bize suyu
sağlayan havayı temizleyen
ormanları Gün geçtikçe daha çok yok
ediyoruz işte İstanbul'un son kalan
Kuzey ormanları da gördüğünüz gibi 3
köprü ve bağlantı yollarıyla
ortasından tam bölünmüş şekilde bundan
10 yıl Sonrasını siz düşünün işte
İstanbul böyle kocaman bir beton çölüne
dönüşmüş durumda insan burada yaşamayı
ister mi hepimizin
hayalinde Artık buradan kaçıp gitmek var
peki kaçıp gitmek çözüm mü Ben kaçtım
gittim
bozdağların Batı ucunda bir orman
köyüne ve orada dedik ki değerlerimize
uygun bir şekilde yaşayacağız ve bir ev
yapacağız oradaki yerel taşlardan
Horasan harcını kullanarak tamamen doğal
malzemeden yalıtımını mantarla yaparak
sırtını da arkadaki yamaca verip toprak
altına gömerek bir ev yaptık bir aktif
ve pasif solar ev Neden pasif çünkü
yazın biliyorsunuz Güneş böyle yukarıdan
geçer saçaklar olduğu zaman o Güneş evin
içerisine girmez akşamları da açarsınız
bütün kapıları akşamın serinliğine evin
içerisine alırsınız koca kalın duvarlar
Taş Duvarlar O serinliği bir güzel
depolar ondan son gündüz boyunca devam
eder ve serincek bir eviniz olur O yaz
sıcağında bu sefer kış geldiğinde Güneş
böyle yukarıdan değil aşağıdan geçer
aşağıdan geçtiğinde saçakların altından
güneşi evin içerisine alırsınız bu sefer
ev güneşin sıcaklığını depolamaya başlar
toprağın sıcaklığını da arkadan aldığı
gibi ev kendi kendine ısınır ama aktif
dedik niye aktif Çünkü ortada
gördüğünüz bu ısıtmalı güneş panelleri
özellikle Kuzey iklimlerine uygun Bunlar
da bir yandan Güneşle birlikte suyu
ısıtır sonra o suyu evin içerisinde
dolaştırır ve soğuk bir Güneşli Kış
gününde elinizi kalorifere dokundurdu
unuz anda yanar 45 dereceye kadar
çıkıyor Dolayısıyla ben doğalgaz
faturası ödemiyorum kömür faturası da
ödemiyorum herhangi bir fatura
ödemiyorum çünkü Doğa veriyor buna o
hizmeti gördüğünüz gibi buradaki diğer
paneller ise fotovoltaik paneller evin
bütün elektriğini elektrik ihtiyacını bu
fotovoltaik panellerden karşılıyoruz ve
şebekeden tamamen bağımsızı Dolayısıyla
ben elektrik faturası da
ödemiyorum su şu gördüğünüz çatı var ya
bir yılda 160 ton suyu depolayabilir
oraya düşen 160 ton suyun biz sadece 45
tonunu depoluyor ve bize bütün bir yıl
boyunca o su yetiyor benim su faturamda
yok
Evet
kaçtım Peki kaçmak çözüm mü acaba Çünkü
ben kaçtıysa dahi Ben orada olmasam dahi
küresel iklim değişikliği hala devam
ediyor su krizi hala devam ediyor iklim
değişikliği hala devam ediyor fosfor
azot döngülerindeki bozulma halen devam
ediyor kaçmam hiçbir işe yaramadı Çünkü
ben de zaten göbekten hala o sisteme
bağlıyım ve o sistem bana ne diyor çalış
diyor satın al diyor itaat et diyor
tüket diyor düşünme diyor sonunda herkes
kendi başının çaresine baksın diyor
Aynen benim kaçıp kendi başı çaresine
baktığım gibi tabii büyük şehirlerden
zombiler geldiği zaman ne olur
bilmiyorum şimdi sistem bunu diyor ve
sistem diyor ki tüketeceksin
tüketeceksin düşünmeyeceksin itaat
edeceksin sistem senin daha çok tüketmen
için kurgulanmış zaten biz nasıl o evi
tasarlarken bir sistem şeklinde
tasarladı İsak aynı şekilde bu sistem Bu
ekonomik sistem de daha fazla tükettirme
için tasar
giriyorsun Markete hiç ihtiyacın olmayan
şeylerle çıkıp gidiyorsun her yıl cep
telefonumuzu değiştiriyoruz Çünkü artık
kaldırmaz oluyor o yükü Çünkü planlı
eskitme bu ekonominin parçalarından bir
tanesi o zaman biz bu sistemi yani
tüketim ekonomisi ve kar maksimizasyonu
üzerine kuruluş sistemi nasıl
dönüştüreceğiz nasıl değiştireceğiz
nasıl bir başka ekonomik sisteme onu
evril şimdi buradaki sorunlardan bir
tanesi kar maksimizasyon unun tamamen
maliyetleri düşürmek üzere o maliyetleri
doğaya ve insanlara mal etmesi İşte bu
maliyetleri Biz insana ve doğaya mal
ederek karımızı maksimize ediyoruz
İnsanları sömürüyor doğayı sömürüyor ve
daha çok
tükettirme içerisinde Güya ekonomik
canlılığı sağlıyoruz ekonomik kriz
olduğu zaman politikacılar çıkıyor Hadi
bakalım daha fazla tüketin ekonomi
canlansın diyorlar bize Şimdi bunu Biz
Alırız da türetim ekonomisi bir mutluluk
maksimizasyon unaa nasıl
dönüştürebiliriz nasıl evr
ebilir kolay mı öyle sistemi değiştirmek
Koskoca sistem öyle heyula gibi duruyor
önünde bunu alacaksın da buraya
götüreceksin dalga mı
geçiyorsun şimdi bu konuda fizik bize
çok güzel bazı ipuçları veriyor
1970'lerde Doğan katastrof teorisi diye
bir teori var katastrof teorisi diyor ki
büyük bir felaketten sonra sistemler
kendilerini yeniden oluştururlar ve
başka bir alana geçer mesela gezegenimiz
burada kocaman bir meteor güm diye
çarpıyor ortalık toz duman İnsanlar
ölüyorlar en sonunda kalan küçük bir
insan grubu o topluluğu tekrardan Yeni
Baştan inşa
ediyor veya küresel iklim değişikliği o
boyutlara geliyor ki kitlesel olarak
ölüyoruz ve ondan sonra Geride kalanlar
yeni baştan yeni bir toplum
üretiyorlar Bunu ister miyiz acaba böyle
bir dönüşümü zannetmiyorum Bu kadar
acının üzerine yeni bir sistemi
oluşturmak ne kadar büyük bir
yük ama bir umut doğdu 1980'lerde ortaya
çıkan Kaos teorisi bize dedi ki
şayet küçücük bir kelebek kanatlarını
çırpsa ta Türkiye'de Bir fırtına kopar
dedi Demek ki benim bugün yaptığım küçük
küçük iyilikler küçük küçük adımlar
belki gün gelir çok büyük değişikliklere
neden olur Bir umut belki ama belki de
olmaz bilmiyoruz Kaos teorisi bunun
garantisini vermiyor
bize ama yine de yapmak lazım bugün
Yaptığımız her küçük şeyi yapmak lazım
ama
1990'larda ortaya çıkan karmaşıklık
teorisi bize çok büyük bir ümit verdi
karmaşıklık teorisi şunu söylüyor şayet
yeter sayıda birey aynı şeyleri yaparsa
o sistem bir dengeden diğer dengeye
kayar ve yepyeni bir sistem oluşur diyor
yani Dolayısıyla Biz Kaos e değil ama
karmaşıklık teorisiyle
şayet hep birlikte kalabalık olarak aynı
şeyleri yaparsak o zaman sistemi bir
türetim ekonomisine ve Eee mutluluk
maksimizasyon çevirme şansımız var Ve
bunu artık bu kalabalıklar bütün dünyada
oluşmaya
başladı ekonomik geçiş hareketleri şu
anda Kuzey Avrupa'da Eee Kuzey Eee
Amerika'da Yani medeniyyet dediğin tek
dışi kalmış canavarın yaşadığı
bölgelerde de bunun çok farkında
oldukları için artık orada Bu hareketler
çok büyük bir şekilde güçlenmeye ve
artmaya başladı aynı zamanda Dünyanın
her tarafında ekolojik ve sosyal açıdan
adil bir geleceği yaratmak üzere yeni
bankacılık sistemleri pıtrak gibi
çıkıyor Dünyanın her yerinde Bugünlerde
ve işte Türkiye'de de artık good
fortrust org platformunda pek çok insan
şu anda binlerce insan bir araya gelmiş
durumda ve onlar da Eee birer tüketici
değil türetici olmak üzere yola çıkmış
durumdalar Adil doğayla dost insanla
dost ekonomilerin desteklenmesi için
Gönül koymuş insanlar Türkiye'de de
artık bir araya geliyorlar Ve o insanlar
aramızda da olan özlem atabaş Eee kurmuş
olduğu işletmedeki Aslı Aysun Fatma ile
beraber oluşturmaya çalıştıkları bu yeni
ekonomide bizlere sağlıklı gıdaların
ulaştırılması için çalışıyorlar
kendileri tamamen organik hiçbir
kimyasal
ve ilaç ve gübre
kullanılmamış içeriklerden
oluşturdukları
özenle titizlikle ve kalplerini koyarak
yaptıkları bu
yiyecekleri daha sonra bizlere
ulaştırıyor ve biliyoruz ki bizim burada
Yediğimiz yiyecekler artık Zarar vermiş
olan veya
Eee insanların sömürüldüğü bir sistem
değil Çünkü bu işletmede
geka kadınlar bütün haklarını aldıkları
gibi Dünya Kadınlar gününde Hatta
çalışmıyorlar Bayram yapıyorlar tamamen
bir sosyal işletme özellikleri de
taşıyan bir yer geko işte geka Özlem ve
eşi
Serhan geçimlerini sağlamak için
bu alanı genişletmek için büyük bir
çabayla mücadele ediyorlar Onlar bu
ekonominin içerisinde var olabilmek ve
bizlere tamamen kimyasallardan arınmış
sağlıklı gıdaları ulaştırmak için çok
büyük bir gayretin içindeler yine burada
Muzo Aynur ve Serkan da patronlarının
iflas etmesi sonucunda ödemediği
maaşlarına karşılık devraldıkları kazova
işletmesinde
tamamen hakkaniyete dayalı bir şekilde
işçilerin kendi sahip oldukları bu
işletmede makinaları tamir ederek
burada büyük bir emekle tamamen
patronsuz kazakları bizlere ulaştırıyor
dolayısıyla hakkaniyetli bir iş modelini
hayata geçirmiş insanlar
bunlar yine İzmit'ten bir örnek Vakfı
Kebir ekmek fırınının o kokulu çıtır
çıtır ekmeklerinin arasından hiç tahmin
etmeyeceğiniz bir ürün
çıkıyor Yavuz Normalde çöpe gidecek olan
Külleri alıyor topluyor onları
işletmesindeki e kazanların içerisine
koyuyor orada suyla birleştiriyor
kaynatıyor Ondan sonra süzdükten sonra
elde ettiği kül
suyunu Aynen piyasadaki deterjanlar
kadar iyi temizleyen bir Eee temizlik
malzemesini kendisi üretiyor yine eşi
Gülnur doğal bir malzeme olan sabun
cevizlerini alıyor kaynatıyor onları
süzüyor ve öyle bir sıvı sabun yapıyor
ki köpür köpür köpürüyor ve endüstriyel
sıvı sabunların yerine geçecek tamamen
doğal kimyasallardan arındırılmış
gezegeni kirletmeyen bir sabun
üretiyor ve onların derdi
de kar maksimizasyonu değil Onların
derdi size daha fazla daha fazla küy
suyu satmak değil Onların derdi geçim
sağlamak geçimlerini devam ettirmek
istiyorlar insanca ve onurlu bir şekilde
yaşamak
istiyorlar İşte bu ekonominin içerisinde
onların yaşamak ve var olmak için
gezegenin Alarm zillerinin çalmaması
için ihtiyacı olan şeyler
tüer Çünkü onların ürünlerini onların
bize yaptığı bu hizmetin karşılığında
geçimlerini sağlayıp onurlu bir yaşam
sürdürme derse bu yeni ekonominin
doğmasına imkan yok ama artık binlerce
türetici geliyor ve bu Türe ekolojik ve
sosyal açıdan Adil olan İşte bu türetim
ekonomisini
destekliyorlar şimdi Hayal etmenizi
istiyorum özlemden binlerce hayal
edin patronsuz Kazaktan binlerce hayal
edin Yavuz ve Gülnur binlercesini hayal
edin ve milyonlarca insanı hayal edin
onların bu üreticilere destek Olduğunu
hayal edin işte o
zaman buradaki bu korkunç ekonomiyi
yaşadığımız bu kabusu gezegeni yok eden
bu sistemi bizim alıp o kalabalıklarla
dönüştürerek yepyeni bir ekonomi bir
türetim ekonomisi bir mutluluk
maksimizasyon unaa çevirmemiz
mümkün Hepinize çok çok teşekkür
ediyorum harekete katılmak isterseniz GF
tr.org
sorularınız olursa Uygar GF tr.org
[Müzik]
CH